I you got to take it back here to take
back what you just said
I'll you have a chicken neck say I had a
bird Mackey didn't say take him back but
now that you said a chicken neck you
need to take back the fact that you said
I have a bird neck and a chicken neck
and I'll tell you why and I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna raise my voice while you
take it back because your neck like a
kiwi bird need you to take that back to
you no I need you to do on this podcast
what shut your [ __ ] mouth you shut
your me and my boy hearing me talking
about some serious stuff Chris is my boy
I think it looks more like a stack of
Dimes his neck hey dude how do you think
Chris uh yeah I could see that I've seen
old pennies I know we get a roll of
pennies guys bang I was a wrestler net
this doesn't bother me because I
actually have a thick neck I've only
tried in pageants as fighters count
yeah I haven't well no cuz my neck is
expansive its athletic I have an
expansive athletic I'm an expansive
athletic neck hey I swear to god you
know yesterday I did that video of you
being a prism wizard yeah I swear to god
a a genuine person DM means like hey
listen I you know I'm a big fan of you
and Cal and I bought follow the show and
I see Callen on the video he goes he's
not looking good she goes I don't know
if I can sleep or eating you do look
skinny
I know what's your I'm first of all yes
I have called but to I'm doing the
[ __ ] that until she said some I
didn't like he does look a little draw
I'm looking this how you're like sunken
in I know do a he's no idea to do this
new time in front of Chris yeah yeah
look man I I take the edge off I'm just
taking I can explain explain the leap
that Chris are you in Scientology now
doing lathe I knew it
kratom cranium clade lathe we flav
kratom kratom which I could use you can
use a lot of things buddy
introduced a lot of things introduce
Chris Bell ruled the pile of dirt I
loved your bigger faster stronger that
love bigger stronger faster stronger
faster which was a great just an amazing
documentary
thank you what how many documentaries
have be done today
so that was my a leap of faith is my
fourth full-length oh right and you did
what beef between this so I did
prescription thugs was my last one yes
that was good to do so I talked about
you know my drug addiction and also like
the addiction that plagues America a
leap of faith also covers that you know
it's a huge problem don't you in that
prescription thugs don't you relapse -
yeah I did yeah I was so bummed like
he's going through a like oh he's doing
well so I'm gonna and I say in a leaf of
faith as a filmmaker I like you know
being a documentary filmmaker you're not
a millionaire you don't make a lot of
money so I'm just cruising along you
know through life you know doing
whatever and I made this um you know
like I I don't even know what I was
gonna say there but I I was doing
prescription thugs and I relapse because
the money from that was a promise for
the funding got pulled for this address
and when the money got pulled it was
like really stressful I didn't know how
to handle it
so I just went back to doing pills and
there I was I was ordering not ordering
I was calling people on Craigslist at
the time and ordering pills from like
huh you know I just call him dudes and I
lived in like Sun Valley so I Drive from
you know here and I lived in Venice at
the time and I Drive up to the valley
you know an hour away just to go get
pills and I was getting xanax
painkillers
you know you name it off of the Internet
and I'm just thinking my god nobody'll
nobody will find out right but it's not
that nobody finds out you just start
slippin and everybody starts what do you
start to see what field so take me
through for a second like you so you're
under all this pressure
what is the can you describe the draw
and what the pills do for you hmm
cuz cuz I can understand blow I've done
blow I've done mushrooms I've done we
where you you did like I know that with
blow you feel like it just feels so good
sure you know dope you know I've never
have done okay I know you had an issue
oh yeah
take it easy bro happen in five years
it's a real thing so obviously and but
but what is the draw so you you what
it's like an angel dumping it actually
feels like a giant warm hug you know yes
you just feel like cozy actually how
does that happen in like 20-30 minutes
you know a glorious you just start
feeling like a little fuzzy and happy
and everybody becomes really nice you
know you're just happy to see everybody
and it's kind of like that feeling after
you had a couple beers and you're at a
party yeah and you're kind of like oh
yeah I'm all fired up but it's not the
bad part yeah and it you don't really
get the bad part cuz usually like fall
asleep or pass out by then but as you as
you go along and you get more and more
addicted you just need more and more
pills and that becomes a real problem is
that you can't keep up with the amount
of pills that you need to even feel good
anymore so you know here alone yes I
think we'll go to heroin
did you ever mess with that no I didn't
thank God my brother my older brother
Mad Dog who passed away had messed with
it and that's when things went really
downhill for him was like that's when I
you know took a serious turn now he
didn't he didn't die from heroin he died
from in a sober living house and we
still don't really know exactly what
killed him we just got a phone call one
day that he was dead
so there was no real closure there there
was no real I really really touched me
when in the in the documentary and he
started to cry remember that well yeah
of course you remember that there's
Farley it really really affected me man
I could see he was he was having a
really hard time it's I think you kind
of went take it easy you know I think to
me like the greatest thing that I've
ever done in my life was put my brother
on film
my older brother yeah and the reason I
say that is when you watch bigger
stronger faster and you come away from
it there's not one person that asks like
how's your brother Mark doing how smelly
nobody asks that because they look at
him and they saw this kid who was like
connected to what he was doing he was an
athlete he was you know serious about
what Mad Dog had this struggle that I
think so many people have but they're
too scared to talk about and I think his
courage and bravery in that movie which
wasn't to him courage and bravery it's
as who he was he was never afraid or
ashamed
to talk about it you know you talked
about like I never notice you never know
I might get noticed you know he says
kind of ridiculous really delusional
well you know I hear a lot of it when I
when I when I watched him do that I've
been in LA a long time and I was in
Venice for a long time sure
rough 17 years yeah you know and and I I
knew a lot and I worked out at Gold's I
knew a lot of those guys and when I say
a lot a lot a lot and I spent a lot of
time with those guys mainly because I
was a struggling actor and I wanted to
be I came here to be an actor and famous
and all that stuff and I I saw so much
of that man and when I saw him I went I
know so many people that's the story of
Los Angeles to a large extent and there
was such a vulnerability with that guy
didn't really bro you feel because you
had a really interesting career I think
a lot of people don't know like you you
had a lot of you know big things come up
and then fall through and yeah like how
did you deal with that like how do you
get I was lucky because I don't have a
chemistry that does well with substance
even coffee and you know too much I'm
very sensitive and that's just luck of
the draw
sure that has nothing to do with self
control I don't like when people that
yeah even my diet I've always been a
moderate person I'm the guy that can do
blow and stop two lines in you know I
can I just have don't have that
chemistry and I'm just lucky so I had to
find other ways to deal with it one of
the ways that dela was was to almost
quit another way I dealt with it was to
quietly freak out wake up and not sleep
you know and but I had I think I figured
out ways to somebody who is older said
look this anxiety these panic attacks
this feeling of failure is just energy
so why don't you take that energy and
put it into work why don't you take this
desperation and this this this terror
that you're gonna fail and put it into a
story and put it into your standup and
why don't you talk about who you'd
rather be versus who you are and that's
how I that's why I spent oh I don't know
and I'm not kidding fifteen years
writing 28 scripts most all of which
didn't go
all of which is a really good right I
don't think many people realize that I
also say this about Brian did you hear
these stories especially in LA of people
not make it and failure and stuff like
that the difference between a lot of
those people I'm Brian and I don't think
Brian I I do think Brian's work ethic
and some other things is what got him
here but I'd say the main thing that got
him here is talent by honest yeah pretty
I yeah I know I'm there I get like I
don't think there's there's a spectrum
and I think there's people work their
ass off maybe to put me on that spectrum
who worked their ass off and get to
where they're going and hopefully they
get some big breaks and then there's
other people who are so talented they
don't have to do everything right but
there's still there's such a level of
talent well I appreciate it John Joe you
know there's the athletes yeah there's
the freighter
there's the free he's a friendly a
comedy freak yes well thank you but but
you know remember there was nothing we
hadn't [ __ ] up yes no but there's a
caveat I was buried you're right first
of all I think that it's an important
thing to talk about because I I was the
kind of guy was never gonna give up I
don't give up that's now I'm never
giving up like whether it was Taekwondo
or wrestling or whatever I just was
never gonna give up I mean you're gonna
have to kill me before I stop that's how
I am but my work ethic I was I was I
self-sabotaged a lot this [ __ ]
watching him the consistency the details
that he pays attention to he's
unstoppable I've learned a lot from him
I'm a lot older but I've learned a lot
being friends with him for five six
seven years now and if I had been around
people like that I didn't surround
myself with people who are that
effective and disciplined I surround
myself with people who are broken Birds
because it made me feel comfortable yeah
that was also full of self-sabotage I am
very familiar with self-loathing with
self-sabotage with all the things that
come with drug addiction I I know it
very well so that's why my heart breaks
when I see people who had that option I
didn't have that option because it just
didn't work it's a it's easy to turn to
something else and just go like this is
gonna solve my problem so yeah when you
said like what does it feel like some
days it'd be like five o'clock in the
afternoon
I'd be like I'm just gonna check out for
today and I just take a bunch of pills
and then like fall asleep and be like 5
in the afternoon like the day hasn't
even you know really started yet so it's
like I would just bury days I'd be like
I wish I could fast-forward to like next
month and it could be you know because
some of these problems will be over and
I'll be on to the next thing or you know
did you have did your what was your
father like because for me the huge part
of it is also my father was the most
determined person on the planet my
mother when I growing up my mother said
your father when I would go jogging with
him I swear to God my mother would go do
not do not run ahead of him because he
will he will keep up with you and he
will die he will have a heart attack
that before he let you beat beat him
that that's my dad and I grew up with
that example as a man and so I I mean
she would literally sit me down and get
dead in my face my mother's not a
serious person because do not do like
like I don't want to lose my husband
that's how [ __ ] crazy my dad is my
dad I grew up with that so what was your
dad like he was awesome and a lot of
times when I stop and think like
sometimes I just stop and think would my
dad be proud of me right now like what
I'm doing and the the phone call I got
from my dad I'll get emotional talking
about it but he was the one that
basically stopped me from doing drugs
because he called me and he yelled that
man he said I don't know what's wrong
with you but you're a drug addict or
something there's something not clicking
with you I don't know what it is and I
hung up the phone I just cried for half
an hour straight yeah and it was like it
was a couple months after that that I
got sober there was another person in my
life Peter Berg you guys might know yeah
Pete he's great render dude he's [ __ ]
awesome he he changed my life to because
he was somebody that I was working with
I did my movie trophy kids with and and
he had told a juicer of mine like hey
you guys got to talk to Chris like he's
all disheveled he smells like vodka like
what's his problem you know he's so
[ __ ] talented and I saw him at the
the UFC fight Nate Diaz and uh
Conor McGregor the second fight and he
came up to me and gave me the biggest
hug and he said you look [ __ ] great
and like to me like I'm I'm getting
choked up to me and the other person I
saw was Rogan who I love and respect
right so it's
people like I want to be like that have
inspired me back to come back to to do
these things that I'm doing and people
ask me like why in the gym doing so much
wait why are you trying to get abs at 45
you know why are you trying to do this
and I'm like because I can and I'm still
alive and I had rolled over and played
dead for so many years that you know now
I feel great so why not why not explore
these with your documentaries you talk
about funding
I'm surprised some of these documents
when they don't get picked up by Netflix
or Amazon you don't get distribution
yeah you get to try and do those deals
before you make the video yeah yeah you
know like basically like the way to do
the way that we do documentaries is like
you raise you know you raise some money
you go shoot the thing and I mean you
know you sell it later on but there's
the Netflix kind of kills you you know I
love Netflix don't get me wrong so they
can tell you what the deal I'll give you
an example so you know like on our movie
I can't I can't discuss numbers but like
on our movie they're gonna have it for
two years and it's like which one a leap
of faith okay they'll have it for two
years and they're paying like a like a
tenth of what it costs to make you know
what I mean for two years and that's
like kind of the only big chunk a month
money will make money on iTunes and and
other things like that but but after the
two years or is it exclusive it'll go
it'll it'll we'll have the option to
either renew that or go somewhere else
and it's not just Netflix as all the
streaming platforms and all that's gonna
change because people are gonna get mad
that they're not getting residuals from
Netflix there's gonna be I think a big
turnover of that stuff it'll be easier
to make films but for documentaries it's
it's really rough but you can but you
can be on Netflix you can be on YouTube
and everything right so on yeah the same
time that leaks is an exclusive it's
hard to sell your movie everybody wants
your movie for free yeah so it's just
like them like the music industry has
yeah almost anybody can get my movie
like if they want to define a leap of
faith I'm sure there's torrents out
there people downloading it and [ __ ]
like that and you know to me I just want
people to reel it to see the movie but
we obviously want a return on investment
and we want to make money on it we're
really good at what you do
thank you yeah I mean you've been you've
talked about trophy kids on this pod
Calvi kid
yeah I fetched stronger yeah trophy kids
was a crazy movie now I got to see that
I've only seen bigger faster it's just
about parents investing all their time
and energy into what their kid does
because maybe they didn't do it or they
want their kid to be what they weren't
and it's just there's that the one you
were talking about the father with the
daughter who's a golfer and stuff yeah
yeah yeah helicopter parents and you
know they want this dream for the kid
with a kid they they're taking away
their childhood what what is how not to
parent me yeah how not to parent hey
have you seen because I've heard when I
when I look at my kids play tennis and
I've looked at the kids that are really
good when they're 12 they almost never
go on to be pros could they played like
that in tens of the kids in my film all
kind of either dropped out of sports so
this kid justice he's a great kid his
dad was just really abusive towards them
and he got a girlfriend and dropped out
of football yeah and I couldn't be more
proud of that kid he's to turn into such
a great kid he you know he's on social
media I see him it's kind of talked once
awhile where'd you get the idea for
trophy kids we don't like to my friends
I think you might know Leland he trained
at Gold's Gym to he's like six foot
eight he's huge he was a basketball
player at Michigan he was my best friend
and we were I was one of his practices
he was coaching AAU basketball a high
level you know he played at University
of Michigan so he it was a really high
level basketball players training all
these young kids who are at the top of
the league and I'm here and I'm talking
to this mom on the phone and he's on
speakerphone and the moms like well I'm
trying to put more weight on them you
know like I gotta fatten him up for next
year and we got to get more weight on
him so I think I'm whole I'm gonna hold
him back and he's like you're gonna hold
him back in school she's like yeah I
mean all the kids are doing it now it's
like we'll just hold them back a year
he'll get bigger and I'm watching it
going like she's fatten the kid up for
the slaughter basically like this is
this is like an investment of time money
energy and focus for this woman that
she's putting all of her eggs into this
basket of this kid hoping that he's
gonna get the college scholarship from
me unless I got a kid like Shaab over
here who very early on is showing that
he's faster and stronger I'm not like so
much of it as how are your parents with
it were they cool yeah Lucy do it oh
sorry he was
you see he was already out be split up
but also that what they don't realize is
it mostly athletes specially the
first-round draft picks in any sport
they played everything man yeah burn
them out yeah what also what recruiters
and what Scouts look for is a kid who
played every they don't like when a kid
just does one nowadays but they
specialize now how do you get I don't
want specializing really no so how do
you get don't know when you're when
you're playing like on it like that
don't they deal with béchamel yeah they
don't they were baseball's a little
different this year round but different
that bad
yeah if you know Charles to look when he
trained like yeah tons of Olympic
athletes yeah and he just says
specializations [ __ ] like that's
it's a bad ideas quote why do you think
it's the thing to do and focus on it's
not the way to go and I would I would
agree with that cuz I've seen way too
many kids you know they they can't do
anything really out there not even
really athletic they can shoot hoops
like crazy because that's all they do
yeah but once you get them on the court
to do anything else like hard to get
them to move well with child actors that
could I'm on the Goldbergs and I've
worked a lot of kids you know and
sometimes seventh heaven when when you
watch these kids who are Hollywood
actors who've grown up acting and
they're homeschooled I'm telling you
dude watch them try to throw a ball or
shoot a basket
I bet and and what's really interesting
also is I think because they never do a
lot of physical activity they don't
really grow like their bodies don't that
they did the bodies don't need to kind
of response world it's a really weird
grow up as a kid isolated right you know
seventeen-year-old how to throw a ball
excuse an American seventeen-year-old
and he didn't know how to throw a ball
and it was I could not believe it good
actor but I'm sure I was like dude yeah
that's wild yeah he just never had done
and we I talked to him about it I he
said no I never really did sports
speaking of sports lifting all stuff my
brother said look at my shoulders and I
somebody told me I got comments
yesterday yeah you're undercover power
lifter maybe
dude you would need to know couple
things one is I work at vanna's barbell
Club oh you do okay I'll - I do CrossFit
three a box three hugs
I got a headline this is a thinness I've
ever seen what do you do strength I know
you're into like live like me in a
powerlifting or it was a joke no I i'm i
do i do i do snatch and clean and i do
that's awesome olympic lifting I know
I'm trying it's not it's great yeah I
need to I'm so I'm cuz I my psoriasis
I'm honest restricted that for a month
so I'm probably look skinny don't know
anyway again do you obviously we're
gonna talk about the the new doc coming
out but do you have one in the chamber
for your next one yes so right now my
brother Mark and I are doing a
documentary revolving around nutrition
and no so so you know these
documentaries they take a long time to
like form that's why I tell people I
don't really know you know it's like you
can ask me all you want but like what is
the movie I don't know yet because we
didn't really we're taking the journey
now I'm not on the journey now so right
now I'm doing a carnivore diet which is
explained to the list it's an all meat
diet mostly red meat by putting red meat
at the center of the diet what you're
doing is red meat basically like the
most nutrient-dense thing probably on
the planet
is beef liver or just liver in general
if most animals do it has the most
nutrients so if you look at like
vitamins minerals and macronutrients and
everything which would be like the
superior superfood probably beef liver
the second on that list is probably
going to be beef you know like steak and
so when you're looking for nutrients to
provide your body steak has every single
nutrient that you need besides maybe
some vitamin C in the absence of eating
glucose or carbohydrates we don't need
vitamin C so basically steak has the
full profile of everything I need if I
load my body up with that I'm never
hungry I don't want anything else for
every meal you're just Sunday's chunk of
steak or a burger patty you know things
like that look you guys saw me outside
of a hot dogger yesterday I was getting
gettin some burger so so all yours how
many meals are you eating a day there's
usually beef usually that's two two to
three maybe and so not a lot of a ton of
calories in those meals no no there's a
lot of calories in beef yeah yeah
there's a lot of calories and then on
the lot of calories and beef like for
example when I went to the place hopped
out yesterday that's probably 2,000
calories you know cuz it's grass-fed
be beefed which is really high in fat
and um there's probably like 40 grams of
fat 40 grams of protein lipid levels
know that have you yeah yeah done my
blood work and my blood work my blood
work looks great you know my
triglycerides were 77 my HDL cholesterol
was 77 my LDL cholesterol was at was
elevated like 305 right she's and people
people will freak out about that but the
problem is that nobody my yeah that's
that's off the charts exactly because
I'm you get tax 165 they're like hey be
a little careful with that so yeah these
the LDL cholesterol number according to
Peter Atia who I trust more than I trust
any other doctor on the planet Peter T
is an expert in lipids and keto diets
and he says your LDL number means
absolutely nothing in isolation by
itself so what Peter attea asked me is
like what's your triglycerides and
what's your HDL if those are like
one-to-one ratio you're you're doing
really well
cuz mine are mine are really good
they're yeah my triglycerides are really
low my and my LDL is good but my ACL was
160 and they were like hey man you gotta
start thinking about a statin but I was
like I feel good I don't wait yeah they
want to do on a statin with it that's
what doctor and I don't and I don't know
a ton about how do you feel though doing
this how long have you been on this
question I've been on it for five months
now
so on same time and I feel the best I've
felt in a long time like I said I feel
like I've come back you know and so I
also have a condition right you have
arthritis I have asked you arthritis I
have to fake hips that I got ten years
ago and after I got the hip surgery I
just thought everything was over you
know right and I got really fat I
weighed like 260 pounds you know right
now I weigh like 190 Wow you've lost
that much weight from this carnivore
diet well from Quito and carnivores so
the first thing I did was a ketogenic
diet and so I explained a long time ago
when I was a power lifter and I was good
and I used to be strong back when I was
26 27 years old I just graduated from
USC film school and
was going to gold's gym every single day
down in Venice so I was driving from
like actually I was still in USC when I
started going to Gold's it was like 95
and I would drive from USC downtown all
the way to Gold's like early in the
morning like 6 o'clock in the morning me
and my friend would leave we'd go train
with the big boys down at gold and then
we go back and I'd go to film school a
day but it was great because it was like
this journey into this whole other world
so I would go to Gold's Gym and I'd see
Hulk Hogan and Macho Man Randy Savage
and I trained with Mike O'Hearn who's a
natural yeah so called natural
bodybuilder but he's awesome and I
trained with him and this other guy Ron
fedko and Ron fedko was a power lifter
he's actually now the head of the
computer science department at Stanford
so he's this brilliant guy who who was
shredded and he and he took one look at
me and he said you're too fat you need
to go on a diet like just like like hey
how you doing I'm Chris he goes hey I'm
Ron how you doing you're too fat you
need to go on a diet I would like that
if you want to lift with us you're gonna
have to lose weight you're just too fat
Wow and I'm holy [ __ ] you know what do
you want me to do and he's like go get
get some paper and go write this down
I'm like okay so and he's [ __ ] with me
I go to go get some paper and write it
down I come back and he says red meat
and water and I had meat in water yeah
I'm like what do you mean is this guy
did Rogen's podcast
no no that's Shawn Baker but I'm not yet
doctor Shaun Baker is actually promoting
it now that's Ron so he's really smart
dude he actually won an Oscar for
blowing [ __ ] up in movies
she's a the head of it read neither do
free bread red meat buddy he he made me
go on red meat on water and I yeah he
was on he was on the juice um he told me
to go on this regimen and I I went on
the diet and I lost weight and I won my
next competition and then I stayed on
the diet and I went into the next
competition that even lower body body
fat lower body weight class so I was in
there 242 class when I started with Ron
and then I ended up lifting in 198 for
most of my powerlifting career Wow
because you know he basically took a lot
of weight off of me without taking any
strength off of me and I thought by
losing all that weight my strength would
you know plummet but I benched over 500
pounds at 200 pounds but but so
the bigger question though is with all
this red meat and all that we're also
talking about testosterone derivatives
and stuff that you guys are all taking
I'm sure that's right so when I say
steroids do you consider testosterone
and human growth hormone steroids yeah
you do yeah that's a steroid that's what
it is you know I think there's all the
lot of people like to hide behind this
TRT yeah our HRT you know it's a hormone
replacement therapy or it's yeah
testosterone replacement therapy and
that's all fine and good I'm 45 years
old I have no problem taking
testosterone you know I've been taking
it since I did bigger stronger faster
yeah I did bigger stronger faster to go
on a journey to find out if steroids
were gonna kill my brothers and
obviously it wasn't steroids that killed
my older brother was it was other drugs
right so when when I started that movie
I was setting out to find out like is
this good or is it bad and at the end I
decided like hey in the right way done
through a doctor which is the way that I
do it I think that this is very
beneficial to somebody with fake hips
sure it's somebody with osteoarthritis a
this we talking about deca anabolic
Symphony and just so everybody knows
that's all I mess with I don't take
anything else outside of the realm and I
have tried other stuff I've tried Trend
ballon and I've tried you know all the
different steroids I supposed to do all
these things and you know what nothing
beats food and nothing beats hard
training and nothing and like 200
milligrams of testosterone is all I'm on
now yeah that probably helps but I'd say
even when I've gone off of that I've
gone off of it for months at a time you
know I still stay strong I still stay in
shape I just think it helps a little bit
yeah but I don't think it's I don't
think it's the answer I think the the
diet and the training are the answers
right huh hard work yeah yeah you're the
thing that your documentary showed back
then was just that there isn't a lot of
evidence that that if done not if you do
it if you're doing it like bodybuilders
there's gonna be some issues I think I
walk into Gold's Gym yeah you'll see a
lot of pretty [ __ ] up looking people
yeah from steroids right yeah like it's
from steroids let's be honest anything
the large doses right the problem too is
people will look at those bodybuilders
and the guys on muscle fitness and
that's the epitome of health but
actually I'm sure if you check their
levels it's that's that's more what I'm
interested in that's what my brother and
I are interested in now so like when we
did bigger stronger faster really
concerned about like being jacked and
being big and you know really gods only
get I don't mean to interrupt you but
guys only get Jack brother do yeah it's
really beyond oh my god that guy is Jack
humming if you're in shape that's all
did you check the body for the lady that
made the only remaining warrior instinct
nobody and Jack is for other deer it's
display you're displaying yeah no girl
gives a [ __ ] you have 21 inch Python yes
nobody can I do
I used to think that when I got up to
bench in 500 pounds that like the chicks
would just come flocking get into a
dance class learn had a [ __ ] salsa
and you'll get the girl that I dated the
longest in my life I remember saying her
like a bench 500 pounds and she just
goes is that good I'm like that just
crumbled me and why'd you break up with
her yeah that was in the very beginning
and that sort of taught me like okay
like no they do a further adieu that
yeah you know weird strong yeah
absolutely
I seen him in the mecca and Gold's Gym
dude I was there all the time my uncle
pax was doing that brought me when I was
a kid mr. mr. Venice pecs Beal using
weight packs bills your uncle Clea
that's amazing yeah so this is amazing I
was on a flight and they were like
ladies and gentlemen we're coming home
from the Arnold Classic like ladies and
gentlemen we have an announcement to
make
mr. universe over 70 is on board
everybody give it up for Watts Beale
yeah and it was uncle who wears these
outlandish outfits he's amazing he's an
amazing dude he just wears like these
crazy outfits big top hats and he really
is in the gym everybody knows he's been
around forever yeah he passed away yeah
he did he pass two years ago I'll cheers
yeah yeah he was he was kind of like a
legend smart guy you've read me some
emails he's smart yeah he was he was
around a wealthy man
he'd wear like the spandex like crazy
color you know stuff yeah but that's
what makes that gym tick man I love that
yeah I love that i love iron mint there
yeah
I loved it there the environment
everything I have ever been back in a
while
I'm my problem there and I'm not [ __ ]
Tom Cruise or something but they played
UFC videos on the screen and then ride
be lifting people keep asking me
questions I could imagine you get killed
because I get killed there too but like
you know I'm it's like people want to
come up and talk to you about your movie
in the middle of a set of deadlifts I'm
tough but most people are actually
pretty cool like they wait til you're
done a lot of you know what to tell you
the truth like with what I do because I
am a documentary filmmaker it's not like
that big of deal I love talking to
people sure when people like oh hey I
saw your movie yeah like that's an
excuse not to do a set I feel like
everybody I feel like everybody seen
your movies that's what I mean like I
agree like as far as being a documentary
filmmaker you've been wildly successful
I'm surprising that someone Netflix or
someone or Hulu or Amazon doesn't pay
exclusively and give you a like a
development you know what's give us four
dots money like honestly I think I would
crush people if we did that that the
problem is like no one's ever offered
that to me but the thing is like if I
had access like I watch it all the time
I'm like man I don't have one that's the
thing so alright man
hey Brennan why don't you go ahead and
give see walk oh I actually do have an
agent but they don't do anything so
that's you know that's the problem with
with this world like you have to you
have to hustle and make everything
happen yourself in this world well
nobody's guys - right no one's gonna
give it to you no one's gonna hand it to
you so while you you say I'll be great
like you know when when Netflix does
come calling it'll be after I do like
two or three more so it's like it's
crazy how much you have to prove to the
world for them to come you also got a
you know they're not out there looking
like oh who can we throw development
deals you know what they're giving it
and bring it into you know we gotta make
you know where they are looking they're
looking at our YouTube there and you
even like YouTube people money different
stuff and something that I just haven't
had any of those things come across my
across the table you do need an agent
you need a good agent who is I own and
you know there are certain agents out
there like yeah like CAA
yeah we'll talk I have a scripted
project coming up that I think is
amazing you guys would love it's called
the Menace of Venice and it's about
Gold's Gym in 1982 when Dan duchesne got
there
who was the steroid guru who taught
everybody how to use steroids and he
basically revolutionized America by this
little story that nobody knows about it
was like this guy in Venice who was this
guru who knew every he went to UCLA
library and went through the stacks of
books and read every study on steroids
that you could possibly read and he
created the underground steroid hand
book and he is the guy right so he was
the sort of linchpin between all the
professional athletes the porn stars the
Mafia you know like he had just all this
you know thing and so I presumably
wanted him yeah I put together a pilot
and we have we have some really good
people attached to it and we're gonna go
out with that now Dan Duchesne is
actually kind of a skinny guy that's
John Romano he was in bigger stronger
faster but he's steroid nation the book
right there that's I bought the rights
to this book it's by an author Shawna
Salle who is an amazing author for ESPN
and he wrote this this whole book and as
soon as I read it
Gold's Gym Venice you know I'm like Dan
duchesne I love him and Dan Dechaine was
actually the guy who definitely was a
was a pioneer of the ketogenic diet as
well Wow
everybody meet whose aunt who was my age
and who does testosterone tells me I'm
an idiot for not being on it and I know
I wouldn't say I wouldn't say an ad and
I would still not only go to your doctor
you get your levels checked you see
where you're at and if it's low you you
get on it but I think like if you look
at dr. Shaun Baker who is a guy that
talks about the carnivore diet the guy
that was on Rogan he's 50 years old he
has World Records in indoor rowing like
on the concept to roller machine it was
really pretty brutal as you know and um
you know he his testosterone is like 267
I think it was when he's festival
it's really low that's what he thinks
that same thing like if you're he thinks
that like with his diet and what he's
doing that maybe he doesn't need a whole
lot of testosterone maybe he's feeling
his body
I think counts that sauce runs high but
when you say that Beato it depending for
you let's talk about the comic I know
what is your what's never been you never
your neck no more so you're never gonna
be jack
you know this yeah yeah like you can go
to Venice barbell club and do it six
days a week yeah you're just not just
like my buddy and also 50 yeah 51 seem
very healthy yeah
you know yet more energy than anyone I
know yeah I don'ts the thing I don't
wanna [ __ ] with my endocrine systems I
feel so right so right psoriasis like
that's Reese and what have you done to
so I talked to I've talked to some
people who specialize in it's exhausting
it used to be like oh it's your skin
it's something that might cut by them
something happened where it was Manta
biotics or whatever we still got like
yeah my cup I'm salted anybody liked
about your diet yes
and I'm working with a guy have they
changed it and stuff because I think
since any Galpin oh it means the best
yeah that's that - that's what I love
him yes he's amazing yeah actually yeah
his class okay and he came to the
premiere of my movie yeah he's legit
yeah and so Annie has me working with it
I'm just making sure you know because
I'm like oh you know you can fix that
yeah oh yeah you mean my god by Omar
yeah well every psoriasis you know like
listen almost every problem you know
this girl Diana it was telling me this
girl beautiful girl at Gold's Gym and
she was telling me yesterday about how
she just feels bad because one thing
that she can't fix is acne I'm like well
you can fix acne he goes but the one
thing that you know she thought she
can't fix is acne so it's like you just
Google you know you google diet and acne
and you'll find a link trician and a lot
of [ __ ] right a lot of sugar dairy yeah
and it's not like foolproof it's not
like everything can be cured but also
accutane and proactive and [ __ ] now what
is your take on on nutrition after all
these years after all these years I
through man I need 70 pounds red meat a
day I say no I don't recommend that for
people I recommend I think that for most
people a you know a diet that is high in
nutrients is what's really important and
nutrients are really found the nutrients
that our bodies can absorb really well
are found in animal proteins and animal
fats so they're in there in the animal
meat right and if we don't eat the
animal meat we're just not going to get
that so regardless of what your ethical
concerns are we can take that off the
table like that's not what I'm talking
about right I'm just talking about for
being as optimal as you can be being as
strong as you can be I would say you
know put the animal
teens upfront and animal fats like I
just say like like I do I use I use
steak I'd say grass-fed beef you know
something like that and sort of at your
Center and eggs I love eggs yeah I think
there's not really too much issues with
eggs for most people yeah and also like
we are all different like some people
can't tolerate me but we find that the
people I can't tolerate me are very it's
a very very small amount of people what
about why do I hear dairies always
demonized like it's demonized a lot but
I think it's non these yeah I think it's
a little bit unfair you know because we
say people say well look no cracks for
babies that's maybe a reason but also it
a lot of people have issues with it a
lot of people have us skin issues they
have just all sorts of different issues
with it I eat a pretty low dairy diet I
don't eat a lot of cheese and I don't
eat a lot of you know very stuff but I I
feel like it's okay for a lot of people
and for some people it's just not you
know right for some people it actually
actually helps them get through the diet
like there's some people that are used
to being you know let's his face like I
was fat my whole life so I can say it
some people used to be in a fat guy I
have fat guy mentality so when I eat
something I want bacon and cheese honey
yeah and you know avocados smashing
there in South galaxies but I have a fat
guy mentality and a ketogenic diet
there's a lot of people that will hear
me talking and I believe this goes
[ __ ] it's not good for everybody
involved it enough to know that there
are healthy ways to do things and
there's but I also said I always say
that with Brian where with diets like
this is what works for me exactly I work
for you I don't know that's what that's
what I'm doing and I see great benefits
from and Brendan that's the disclaimer I
was trying to throw out there so people
know that like yes not every die is good
for everybody
but there are a lot of things that we
have in common that we can talk about
right but one of the things that we
really need to look at is processed
carbohydrates that's usually the problem
in most people's diet anything that
comes in a box bag or can yeah it is
probably not to be consumed by humans
right but everything we eat comes out of
a
Boxberger can nowadays so we have to try
to avoid that as much as possible yeah
you know try to eat from nature as much
as possible I really don't think there'd
be a lot of obesity on the planet if
people just ate what came from the earth
and that's it yeah right so regardless
of carbohydrates or macronutrient intake
I don't think you need to be seventy
percent fat and zero percent carbs in
order to get lean I think you need to be
zero percent [ __ ] and yeah my buddy
Tariq Aziz was in he went to Afghanistan
from 2003 or 2004 to 2008 and he was the
in Afghanistan it was during the war and
but he was eating the food like he would
get his dairy from the cow right there
yeah he was eating the food that was
there they make the bread by hand and
the rice and he said in four years five
years he never had a [ __ ] cold like
in all the stress and all the insanity
he never got sick once and either did
anybody around him he's like the one
thing I'll tell you is that as [ __ ] up
as that place was wait nobody was sick
nobody living think that stuff like
bread could probably be healthy if it
was not preserved for you no way they
make it some sourdough bread like you're
a juiced-up in Venice they they make no
every morning it's like and we know the
problem with wheat you know we've it's
like there's been extensive the whole
documentary on what's what we in ah yeah
there's a lot a lot of issues with like
wheat and grains that people have and
like so that's another thing to consider
you know it's also the type of grain
that's grown with Roundup and different
things it may be that it's genetically
engineered so that our body isn't
recognizing it anymore
yeah like there's some some work on on
Holstein cows American Holstein cows for
whatever reason the way they were bred
they produce a protein called alpha
casein a1 mm-hmm that European cows
goats and sheep produce alpha case of a2
in that protein because it's been long
enough our body absorbs it so people say
they're lactose intolerant you might be
actually intolerant to the protein yeah
from Holstein American cow that's
totally true and that's the same with
like egg whites some people have problem
with the protein in eggs not the fat
because it's fed corn and soy so if you
pasteurized eggs everyone bill is just
the egg whites
yeah stupid uncle packed that that it
didn't make any sense right because
you're just eating up eating the protein
no no no it's all the fat was in
you know which is and that's the other
thing people need to realize is your
there is no zero zero zero I can't say
it enough correlation between the
cholesterol you eat and the cholesterol
in your blood they're the people that
they when when we have people keep
saying that you can't eat eggs because
they're high in cholesterol yeah like
that's hurting people because
cholesterol is what testosterone is made
out of cholesterol is what our hormones
are made out of
we need cholesterol we need eggs we need
butter we need like we need these things
you don't want to get rid of it all we
want to precursors yeah we want to we
want to eat these theta eggs and get a
boner I think you know I just think that
I'm gonna take my you're good the more
energy we put in the good energy we put
in the more and good energy we're gonna
put out right so take me to leaf of
faith sure so now you're on these
opiates you have arthritis you can't
stand up you got all these [ __ ]
problems you go through we have you
relapse and then you come across a leaf
yep and somehow this leaf doesn't seem
to have any side effects addictive
properties but it works really well it's
an interesting story so I have a friend
named horseshoe who is a former I'll do
pro wrestler live in LA you have a
friend named Snake Eyes horseshoe yeah
they're people come and reinvent
themselves I knew an actor named mercury
he's wear scarves in the middle of the
summer but you know I get a dick
yeah well horseshoe was nicknamed by a
stripper she thought his hair looked
like a horseshoe so that was like his
his thing but then when he went to WWE
so I used to work for WB as a writer oh
wow I met horseshoe threw that right
through like there's a farm league out
here we got John Cena into the mix right
and my brother and I we were like very
instrumental and getting him involved
with us let me ask you this you being a
writer there and then we're gonna get in
the leaf of faith but how the rest feel
and well I'm saying how the yeah of
course it's not real but as far as the
supplements that they're on yeah but
what's your thoughts on them well
nowadays they have to be they have to be
clean nowadays they test them so they
actually test them and give me a look
they test them for anabolics now is
everybody on the testing list yeah I
don't know because you know some of the
people out there some of you own the
company that are pretty jacked so I
don't know yeah I think Vince McMahon's
is an unbranded what but so that would
be that wouldn't that fall under a
hormone replacement yeah yeah it's funny
how you how you're talking about goes
Jim and John Cena cuz I'm I'm old enough
and I was working out when John Cena was
working it calls just yeah and people
don't believe that he was at the desk
but so my brother and I saw him and when
you saw him back then you're like what
the hell's this guy he's got to be
something right that's what my brother
and I think his hands and wrists yeah
and we said we got to do something with
this guy we gotta you know and so we
just kept talking him into going to
wrestling school and then when he went
to wrestling school he ran the ropes
back and forth took one bump on his back
and said I'm gonna do this for the rest
of my life really
yeah Wow he just knew it he's just super
started blowing up acting - yells me
some money to tell you the truth
when my brother passed away the biggest
bouquet of flowers came from John Cena
John Cena paid for that expenses of my
brother's funeral that's how [ __ ]
cool I mean when Mach when you really
need somebody you know what I mean oh my
parents weren't doing good at the time
is when you really need somebody that
had come through like that and that
makes me like you even more
that's huge so nice also done the most
the most make-a-wish foundation than
anybody in the world even more than the
rock who was the runner-up who also just
said great do you know what I asked him
once I say I need shorts I wanted to get
some shorts that were like fighter
shorts yeah and and he kind of walked me
over and he goes well you know I I don't
yeah I think he'd been in the composing
room or something he goes you know as
opposing room right yeah imposing come
on man and he goes um I I just remember
in saying I know the shorts they're fit
me because I got my ass he never gotten
here's the body foot he never got into
bodybuilding huh he did get into
bodybuilders a little bit just a couple
amateur shows and you know did pretty
well but I think that his calling was
wrestling and I think that was me you
know anything it was it was made for him
I know his trainer is Rob McIntyre and
he's been friends with John since he was
15 and you'll hear him tell stories
about John when he was younger and he
knew he's just like destined to be
somebody like everybody at school knew
John Cena like they will talk about him
like as if he was famous since he was 15
you know he's just one of those people
that are a great presence you know and I
think he says the factor oh yeah so go
back going back to horseshoe and
wrestling and all right yeah so in
wrestling pain killers are a huge deal
my brother obviously was was addicted to
painkillers
I was addicted painkillers but I'm in
Pro Wrestling it seemed like everybody
was addicted to painkillers my friend
Horseshoe was taking 90 pills a day Wow
and you I mean I would be like we'd be a
baby blues barbecue and he just passed
out on the table and we'd like wake him
up when the food would get there and
he'd like wake up and he'd eat and any
guy just goes right back off you know we
were just used to it like that's his
horseshoe he just does that [ __ ] you
know and so um you know he had gotten
sober well he had a massive stroke and
it was about five or six years later um
you know still friends with him and
everything and how is he doing now
well he was doing amazing and I'm like
dude I don't understand this you're like
back to normal
you know what I mean yeah you you had a
stroke Hansie um like I want to say 37
at the time made a good date or a stroke
and so he had this stroke he's about 45
now 46 maybe he had this sort of more
than that maybe like ten years he had
this stroke anyway and he was doing
really well afterwards and he's like I
think it's to create them you know and
he's like have you tried kratom I think
you'd really like it you know and I'm
like what's kratom and I had heard of it
and actually when I was doing
prescription thugs
I had actually tried it but it didn't do
anything and my intention when I tried
it during prescription thugs was it was
during the time that I relapsed so I was
actually trying to get it to see if I
could get off those pills or to see if
it made me high to see what I felt from
it right and I took emember getting
quite um I took seven pills at one
like I'm just gonna load up this shit's
gonna be great the extremists that take
seven in you know
nothing happened so there was only like
three left I bought like a bottle of ten
figure well I'll take the whole bottle
like I'll take all ten so I take the
three more nothing nothing happened so
to me it's a wash it's worthless right
but for some reason when my friend
brought it back to me you know years
later and I tried it and my intention
was like I'm in a lot of pain right now
my body really aches and I took it all
of a sudden the pain was gone and I
don't know if it's because it was a
different kind of create I'm a different
you know think so then I was like okay
well this is weird because like last
time it didn't really work for me and so
I tried and it took me about three or
four months and it skeptical so very
skeptical to see what's strong in that
case it took it very skeptical and then
like I have chronic pain to the point
where it feels like I'm paralyzed from
the waist down like I can't bend at the
waist I get I get really you know stiff
and I was really stiff and after I took
the kratom ah I wasn't stiff anymore I'd
be like stomp I was stopping on the
ground trying to go like it's got a hurt
like it's gonna hurt the pain will come
back right yeah I'm trying to make it
you know come back and and it wasn't
coming back and so after you know a
couple weeks of taking this and being
able to move better and going to the gym
and like going to do a squat and it
doesn't hurt yeah I'm like wait maybe I
can squat again maybe I can deadlift
again maybe I can do some of these
things that I haven't done in a really
long time again I started doing that and
then you know one thing leads to another
you start getting in better shape and
you feel better so it becomes a snowball
effect and so for me it was just like
this great snowball effect that started
me on a path to getting back in shape
you're starting on a path to get back to
health and what also happened was in
between this I was on dr. Drew's podcast
and dr. Drew had brought up to me
hey if you take Advil and Tylenol in
combination it's actually been shown to
be more effective than opioids and so
I'm like oh that's really interesting
advil and what tylenol entire in
combination what's the difference ones
ibuprofen and ones acetaminophen
okay so both bad for your liver though
right well that's yes this worm get to
it that's great and all and I started
doing that for like six months and then
I got a phone call from a friend who
lives in England who was a
body builder who said he was taking so
much Advil that he had to have a kidney
transplant
and he said I'm a hunter taking about 20
a day he was a bodybuilder and he was
taking opioids and he got off the
opioids and name was taken yeah you're
in a lot of pain so I was taking ten
advil and ten Tylenol a day so to me
that scared the [ __ ] out of me you know
and he said hey should I've had a kidney
transplant but then I found another guy
Tom Prince who was a pro bodybuilder he
told me that his transplant kidney
transplant was due to NSAIDs as well
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
I've listened to Rhonda Patrick on Joe
Rogan's show talk about the 16,000
deaths that we have from Advil and
Tylenol and things of those nature
16,000 deaths a year and also how it
disrupts your gut microbiome yeah and
it's what's called don't laugh a cox-2
inhibitor and a cox-2 inhibitor it
because it blocks because it is that it
that raises your risk for a stroke or a
heart attack
I don't like it doubles it right so the
FDA has put a warning on ibuprofen seen
it Yeah right
that says it's a cox-2 inhibitor and it
could cause heart attack or stroke right
and now we find this leaf kratom that
exhibits similar effects in pain relief
but it's a natural plant it doesn't have
all these harmful chemicals in it and
we're not seeing the same issues that
we're seeing with ibuprofen well an
aspirin is also derived from plant smart
from bark yes from what kind of bark
white willow bark white willow bark so
and that was the miracle drug but
aspirin also causes the stomach bleeding
in large cause of some issues yeah and
we don't know yet if kratom causes those
issues I have a feeling that it doesn't
it works on the mule opioid receptor so
it actually isn't opioid and that's one
thing that isn't okay yeah and that's
one thing I think people in the kratom
industry wanted to go like it's not an
opioid the FDA is crazy all an opioid is
by definition is something that works
like an opiate so like inject hockey
season opiate well technically an
aspirin could be called an opioid right
because it
works like it works like a painkiller
right blood right it thins the blood a
so it's it's like but it's but it's it's
kind of subjective what you call an
opioid do we know levels to the zone
yeah when you do when you take kratom it
does it brings down inflammation is that
is that immeasurable yes so I think so
kratom works on pain receptors so it
works on your brain it works on the pain
receptors in your brain okay to sort of
send you a signal saying like hey I'm
not you know I'm not hurting as bad as
you think I am right which for people
that are in extreme chronic pain like me
that's huge but I think the other thing
that people need to do on the on the
other side of it is take something like
curcumin and take something like maybe
CBD oil
these are anti-inflammatory
anti-inflammatories that are also
natural and so I think in combination
you're looking at a double whammy but
for me just taking an anti-inflammatory
doesn't do it I need I need to take
something that take the edge off the
pain as well
so no studies have been done yet on
kratom whether or not it is has liver
toxicity not not a specific safety study
like that but it's been used for you
know over 200 years and in Thailand
oh and Thailand along yeah so I want to
study it's been used forever you know
and any of this so it's isn't it is it
from a tree and we're working yeah we
can you get it so it's in the same
family as the coffee plant right and
it's called MIT Regina speciosa as the
name of the plant I know and I say yes
and so what oh yeah I met you today so
what basically he has a metro time Metro
China you ever see a shoe collection
here so they dishonor this beforehand so
shut up sorry this plant
we're ten year old is like like I said
like coffee plants and the same families
of coffee when they think it's about as
addictive as coffee right now so pretty
time it's addictive to me but no I'm
kidding yes and no like do you like I
mean now I can go without coffee yeah I
can't because you're weak I would do
this you're weak my drink what button do
you have no comment
you have no care look like I have a you
have a good
I'm wearing I don't want to wear a baggy
clothes man worst I've ever seen
[ __ ] cuz I swear hole tonight and
I'd [ __ ] to eat a lot yesterday Kinkos
is he alright I'm like no damage in no
Tim you went I what he's not I I think
here's a drug problem I haven't I
haven't this is why I brought Kristin
because I want these baggy this is what
see I am I ate I ate a lot of chip oat
late last night and I woke up at 4:00 in
more like I'm full that's how delicate I
I don't swear I'm saying
I'm weak that way Chipotle yeah so I
can't you can take a bunch of pills if I
before I go to battery no yeah did Andy
Galpin tell you could have that no I had
I had a rice white rice okay
pork and black beans that's I'm just
making sure that you're on galvans plan
no but if I want to trade them where can
I get it you do have to have a
prescription
oh no no crate um you can get I'm sick
you diet I'm I but you know what I say I
speak for all the worse no no I'm sorry
because I get a lot of you like thank
you
you're the light listen you go down
about your [ __ ] kratom look at him
why are you shaking dude he's scared I'm
not shake yeah you are man you want
crater hey no seriously you got what hey
whatever diet you're on
you've got listen to me you've got to
switch it you're in show business your
eyes are sunken in yeah you look like
you've been slept in [ __ ] tired I'm
tired too been traveling a lot bro me
too man no not like me I've been taking
eight planes do you have
we're chill out on the I know stuff keep
going man where were we
about about two miles Austin Tyler where
did it do I have a prescription no
that's a video dark web the beauty of it
is you don't need a prescription you can
get it online you can get so here's a
what I think is a problem right now they
sell it at smoke shops right Wild West
right and and smoke shops are not where
I usually get my supplements you know I
don't walk in
you know Joe smoke shop and go like hey
where's the vitamin C you know it's just
not a not a place where I normally would
go to get it so you know and and most
normal people aren't gonna want to walk
in you know you got a like 60 year old
woman that needs kratom she's not gonna
walk into a smoke shop and get it so I
think that's a huge problem the the
reason why it ended up in smoke shops is
just because smoke shops like you said
are the Wild West and they let them sell
everything so it's sort of been in this
gray area of the FDA for quite a while
right now it's completely it's
completely legal in California it's been
banned in like six or seven states but
that's actually coming back the other
way now they're starting to repeal these
things because I realize I'm like well
[ __ ] we just approved marijuana but we
made cray Tammy legal that doesn't make
any sense right so people are starting
to realize that this doesn't make much
sense to be illegal but you can order
you know on the internet like the place
I get it is the company I use urbanize
natural organics with an X on the end
comm and I just order it from you know
you disorder Fenella and how much is it
ah
is it really expensive it's it's like an
average price for like a normal
supplement like like 50 bucks a bottle
45 bucks a bottle
pretty standard a pretty standard price
I think in the business I'm surprised
you don't 70 or 80 cents a pill but my
brother and I formulated a version of it
called mine bullet and we're gonna sell
it but I wanted to wait until the movies
out I want to wait till the movies out
for a while I don't want people thinking
that like I made a movie to sell kratom
because I didn't I made a movie to help
you create I'm gonna help too and it
helped me a lot so educating people I
know a lot of people and that's why we
want to put it out and my brother and I
look at it a little bit a little bit
differently I we call it mind bullet
because for me it just makes me focus
and it makes me feel really good and so
if I just take two in the you know in
the beginning of the day I feel great
all day and I don't see why no why
everybody else wouldn't want to feel
that way too so that's the way we like
have that do the Thai people have they
always taken this is yes oh okay so like
in Thailand it's just like a natural
normal thing so you know you'd wake up
you know this is like you know
housewives would do this they wake up in
the morning and they walk outside and
they pluck a couple
leaves from their kratom tree and they
throw it in a pot and they'd boil the
water and they make this tea and they
would just drink that throughout the
whole day and feel really good so you
heard of got yeah I have yeah so in the
Middle East and like in Somalia and
places like that and Yemen they chew God
all day long do you know what God is you
ever heard of God no look up god that's
a narcotic that that that so so this is
very common like these kinds of leaves
in a lot of cultures they will in
addition it's a jute yeah it's a mild
there it is it's in Pakistan it's a mild
kind of sedative that people just chew
literally all day their mouths turn
green and then there's betelnut which is
a whole different that was this is
anything happen when they when they eat
this like I mean it's so so good again
what happens is when you chew it
initially nothing happens and then as
you chew it you will get sort of a buzz
to the point where I think it exactly
yeah so it's the point where in like I
think in the Eritrean war between
Ethiopia the eretrians waited till like
the middle of the day because they knew
the soldiers would all be high on God
and then they invaded oh wow I got
[ __ ] it's like being it's like smoking
weed basically yeah I think like when
you go there because I lived there it is
so prevalent like almost everybody you
see is chewing is addictive
so yeah basically it's a very mild it's
a mild it's probably very similar to
kratom like it yeah it's like a little
bit of dick here's the deal with Craig
that's why I'm wandering a crate on the
same fan freedom has like 43 or more
outputs in it and the doctors studying
it the most is dr. Chris mccurdy down at
University of Florida and you know he's
basically been studying it to like
against methadone and you can stack
kratom right up against methadone and
right up against narcan and it has the
same sort of results for getting people
off of opioids right the same same sort
of a timespan that it takes to to get
somebody out of withdrawal right Wow so
we know like all the firefighters are
carrying narcan now which is it's a drug
right it's kind of amazing that we have
a plant that can do a lot of the same
things but nobody's willing in a study I
mean we live in such a backwards
messed-up country when it comes to
nutritional studies and supplements
studies and the things that we
look into the problem with kratom is
there's no huge like money like that if
there was some huge like money person
behind it they said hey let's go do all
the studies like there's not money to do
all these studies and that's that's a
big problem so with the movie we
actually raised some money to do some
more research um with Christmas it's
just hard when it there's not a lot of
money like do you know according to the
Harvard Harvard Medical School I think
her name is Wendy Chen so what do you
think is the most effective today the
most effective measurable prevention
against recurrence of certain breast
cancers and certain and colon cancer
what do you think is the one thing you
could take that has been proven to be
insanely effective and yet they can't
get any studies I don't know aspirin oh
wow a daily aspirin regimen is highly
effective according to the Harvard
Medical School and this woman's research
in it not once you had what was so when
you get it and to prevent a recurrence
of it one of the greatest things for the
Prevention recurrence that has been
measurable is aspirin now money there's
no that aspirins already on the market
so you're not gonna get a pharmaceutical
company to run to sponsor a very very
special spring reps yeah because it's
already there yeah so you can't patent
it you can't do it right you know make a
new delivery system like sprayable
aspirin or something like that and so
that is the problem Sinai's that there
are there are trees it goes back to
Annie Galpin I mean I've gone to five of
these like the skin beat people and they
just they shrug and give you a cream
yeah truth is that there are limitations
to so much of this of a power and also
in clinching yeah and and if you want to
be on the cutting edge yeah you can't
wait around for research so something
that Charles Pollock when the strength
coach taught me that I thought was
awesome I was actually interviewing I'm
a couple weeks ago for our nutrition
thing and he and I was asking him some
questions I'm like yeah but there's
there's no research on that and he's
like you think if I'm gonna train
Olympic athletes I sit around and wait
for the research to come out like I come
up with a training technique right and
I'm like I think this will work really
good and we tried a bunch right do it
I'm not waiting for a study to be done
on it I'm just gonna do it well he also
did a drug or supplement I'm just gonna
take it Charles Pollock winner has more
Olympic gold medalists under his belt
than anybody
but he also reads he has a library
bigger than anybody he reads everything
on PubMed yeah every read everything
that's ever been published and he he's
such a maniac that he's like when he
talks about meat and he's like well my
favorite meat is comes from Canada
there's a certain access deer that runs
from here yeah yeah
it runs from wolves all day this is how
crazy is he goes and the best mean for
me it's like a meat fudge I mean he's
from a Canada as French as first
language is like there's a there's an
excess deer that runs you know it's a
part of a Canada you cannot get there
you must shoot it from helicopter you
must shoot it now they run for you they
run from Wolves all day and what that
does is it creates a lot of glycogen in
the meat so the meats sweet yeah and
there's only one place in Toronto you
can buy it yeah I know that's the way I
mean there's one there's one butcher
there's one [ __ ] butcher one guy
there's one guy so of course he goes
there and gets his meat really there
yeah he's amazing on the same diet as
you he mainly eat some a meat diet so
his poliquin's our main thing eggs me
he's always talked to athletes was
meeting nuts for breakfast he says
there's like high-powered breakfasts
cashews this have a handful of some sort
of nuts and then to have like you know
some meat or some eggs with it and
that's like the high-powered athlete
breakfast he's been around for a long
time I think most of the stuff that my
brother and I do come from either Louis
Simmons who's the powerlifting God or it
comes from Charles Poliquin who's like
the bodybuilding expert you know and we
that we like to do that a lot mark and I
we find a couple people that we really
like and we just sort of pick their
brains my question though to you is when
you have Charles [ __ ] when these guys
are dealing with athletes who are
attacks in their bodies on a high level
hmm all the time I wonder how that works
for a guy like me who's a civilian who
works out once a day yeah I mean look an
athlete can just handle a lot more like
yeah Brendan can handle way more than
wherever we're gonna be able to handle
because just because what he's done in
the past but now though he's like he's
like he works out what 40 minutes a day
and his lifestyle is I think it's in his
DNA I am I think like for athletes I
think in Miami do you think so
yes do you think you could ever be like
I don't know like if some
happening maybe like you're not gonna be
like he's not gonna be like weak and
frail if he doesn't live no that's not
what I mean what I mean is that I wonder
if those diets they're all meat worth
the people that are that are taxing
their bodies on a little athletes are
but then when you retire so he I'll tell
you like um yeah a diet so like you're
talking about like if it would work for
you just yeah I just wonder if I just
wonder if what do you point for Ali that
nine to five person yeah I don't need as
much protein that's what I mean I'd say
your requirements are different right
and also your your goals are different
right so that's another thing so your
requirements for protein are different
you would just eat less but for example
like an all meat diet where you're
cirrhosis syrup psoriasis what psoriasis
yes or Isis processes like the liver
psoriasis I think like an all meat diet
would probably clear that right up
like I think that things like that work
for interventions for like resets you
know things reset and things like that
and so where I would recommend an all
meat diet for somebody's like if they
haven't been feeling good if they have
some sort of like breakout or rash they
got some sort of autoimmune disease
that's running them down they're tired
you know whatever and that is that is
that is autoimmune and you kind of do
like an all meat diet for like two weeks
and see what happens and see how you
feel and if it doesn't work for you just
go back to eating normal there's nothing
detrimental that's gonna happen to
somebody from doing it I just think it's
always worth worth a shot and like my
diets really simple because if you look
at it like realistically I've ended up
losing a lot of weight I've become what
we call metabolically flexible so my
body you know
when you start eating fat for a long
time you know this your body starts
producing what they call ketones and you
go into ketosis right so if I'm in
ketosis half the time and half the time
I'm not I'm what we call metabolically
flexible mark Sisson talks about this a
lot which means that if I have like an
apple I might get kicked out of ketosis
but then the next meal I have a steak
and I'm right back in and so sort of
like teetering on that that edge allows
you to yukita wish it were it actually
allows you to utilize both substrates as
a fuel you didn't
my power for a long time I loved it but
you didn't think you could necessarily
do it if you had been fighting uh I
wouldn't say that I don't know I don't
know I think that um for example I don't
know like this ugh IDO ish this
carnivore thing I feel like an animal I
would really be interested in seeing
somebody do it that fights or something
you know but like also you don't want to
detract from them so like if if Brendan
was like fighting and he's like you know
Chris this diet sucks right I'd be like
okay well let's not do it right yeah but
if but if he felt like I feel like I
feel like an animal I feel like put me
in the cage I mean I'll get killed but
that's it that's how I feel meant like
mentally I feel like I am the strongest
I've ever been yeah and I've never been
stronger and there's nothing there's
there's nothing else diet-wise that I'd
meet like I don't feel like I need if I
could just load up on some carbs I could
really have a lot more energy in the gym
or whatever I literally feel the best I
felt sad yeah well you can and you're
taking kratom yeah because I would
imagine opiates would make you feel kind
of more copacetic than that they don't
make you feel like an animal they make
you feel relaxed yeah right I don't know
kratom is very similar to the way that
opioids feel but I think like opioids
opioids when you take them they in the
beginning they get you kind of fired up
when you take them they give you like a
little bit you know that kratom is any
at all addictive could you stop doing it
right now
yeah I've stopped it for several weeks
like I've when I went to Thailand where
it's from and actually it's illegal in
Thailand which is strange what happened
was bad and everything fly out there
yeah I know and then what happened back
in the day well speaking of letting
everything fly that's why it became
illegal d-boy they they were it started
cutting into the heroin trade so people
would like the migrant workers like the
khat they'd be out chewing it work it
out in the fields and all these like day
workers out in the fields they stopped
they stopped using heroin and so the
government was like well nobody's using
heroin anymore like heroin was on the
decline and the government saw that so
they banned kratom and for years the
government want them on heroin because
they can control control all people they
control everybody right so they that's
why
they want heroin but when it cut into
the heroin trade they made it illegal
and then they they basically burned down
all these kratom trees in Thailand and
now everybody gets in like Indonesia and
stuff like that but it was literally
like if you look it up it'll tell you
like it was cutting into the heroin
trade so much that people stopped using
heroin and we're and we're using kratom
to get off of heroin there was money and
so way back then there was way too much
money in it for that it's like I'm
basically like probably control the
people but also a big part of it you're
right the biggest part of it was
probably the money well yeah I don't
think I don't I don't know that I don't
know this town I have a big heroin
problem because heroines not something
you can do casually is like nobody ever
did a lot of heroin so I don't know
times the Wild West yeah but if you look
it up I mean that's what I've that's
that's what I've read about it's a wild
East you silly goose the drug addictions
devastating Thai villages yeah so in
Thailand it was like it was super
popular and people were chewing it and
getting off the heroin and they were
they would basically the government put
a put a shun on that and then now
couldn't go get it from Indonesia
Malaysia and stuff like that and there's
giant right people use it over an arm
hold on yeah in Thailand don't mix it
with oh they call it four times a
hundred kratom contains four main
ingredients the leaves of local plant
known as kratom cough syrup coca cola
and I see that's the problem that's
that's an abusive thing so like now
people have messed this is and the way
they do it is they use kratom Coca Cola
and cough syrup is that Thai iced tea
huh yeah I'm not talking about doing
that kind of [ __ ] like I don't I don't
do any of that yeah you don't have to
take that I don't think I mean to me
that would probably make me puke but you
know I just used the word build of the
ground-up leaf and a big problem with
kratom is the internet because you go on
the internet and almost everything you
read is negative because it's all come
from the bad publicity that's been you
know coming out for years about it
because people didn't want you to have
it right but it is it is it does seem to
be some other addictive all here says
here an estimated one in five teenagers
are addicts creating kratom is
by far the most popular drug I'll tell
you about the addiction right so it has
two alkaloids under the active
ingredients Matt raden it has my Trajan
team and has this other one called seven
hydroxy Matt Rajah mean seven hydroxy
Matt Raja Deen is found in a very very
small amount in the plant that alkaloids
actually addictive
it's about as addictive as coffee look
I'm a tragedian which is the main bulk
of what makes it up and makes it good
for you like makes it makes you feel
good that is not addictive however once
you take them at Rajini nowt of the
plant you're like adulterating it like
it's kind of [ __ ] up like for your so
it will be better to have one take one
alkaloid out of the plant most likely
and just use that like that might be
better but because of the way the laws
are and everything once we do that then
we have to apply for like a new drug
right thing and there's a lot of issues
with a hole in our alkaloids and doing
things like that so just taking it as
the raw leave seems to work well and
then you know you have this maybe
addiction that's as much as coffee I
don't even feel it's that much like if I
don't have kratom I just don't care
about it I come yeah I'll forget it but
if I don't have it and I have to work
out that day it's gonna be tough yeah
you know that's that's the way I look at
all right well dude you're like a wealth
of information you know the in the the
document you just dropped we're can
people watch it it's on our iTunes
Google Play
Vudu all those like things where you can
add movies anywhere you can rent movies
well you're you're really talented at
what you do man we want John here for a
while I need to watch prescription thugs
who's Yuki was on here talking about
trophy case yeah love trophy yeah yeah
that's that's important that's good man
all right well I'm I'm gonna head to you
guys go get some meat yeah I look at him
now I want to filet I want flaming you I
think you would do amazing on that diet
yeah I think I might try it but you're a
machine what do you do now
Kito ish you do keto ish yo kitto strict
usually Monday through Friday then keto
is Saturday Sunday watch how strong is
it's fun yeah you're crazy my brother
wants to train with you we got
hmmm down here you know let's do it but
he'll be here the whole month of July
really yeah let's get together yeah we
welcome to me we're going got some drugs
I want to get him out no no you're too
skinny let me in if we're gonna do
something funny we'll call you but
alright I think we're gonna be manly
[ __ ] you know dude I told you I always
tell that story wouldn't you and Tim
Tebow walked in on me deadlifting 145
and I stopped I was embarrassed I was
looking at skinny mother she bows well I
got embarrassed reduce go check out the
doc he's one of the best duck makers in
the world it's a proven track record
there's no doubt thank you guys talented
and [ __ ] smart and yeah you're fun to
fun to talk to you thanks man I'll come
in anytime you guys want appreciate me
Chris Bell everybody Chris Bell thank
you guys
let's do sir Iran offense sounds good
well do you even know the movie jackass
you know the guys from jackass yeah [ __ ]
yeah you do have to be a bit more - I'm
friends with steve-o so one another show
Brian yes one of the guys from jackass
you know died a guy named Ryan Dunn it
was a car accident
yeah he was hauling ass I didn't gt3
something like a nice car anyways Hulk
Hogan tweeted what the wrong person in
the tweet so he goes damn BAM I wish you
were still with us I sure would love to
hang out again my brother love you miss
you
Hogan hey and it's a screenshot from
this hello [ __ ] hell Larry God did
this on Monday it's a mistake with a
bachelor that's how you fixed it what
God got ridin Banamex up sorry bad well
okay I'm talking to my buddy Jerry Fagin
he goes he goes hey I go hey goes he
calls me when she never does I go with
Tom because Jimmy's mom died this
morning I go Jimmy Burke oh yeah [ __ ] oh
I called Jimmy I leave a message like
I'm choked up I love his mother I know
his mother really well I've known it for
like you know I'm trying not to cry I'm
like mama I'm so sorry about your mother
she's such a beautiful person I can't
believe she died I don't understand this
she was so healthy call me I'm here for
you I'm coming down to see you I gotta
[ __ ] call like half hour later hi
Brian hello this is Jimmy's mom
from have I'm calling you to tell you
thank you for being so sad am i he was
[ __ ] his mom and he's going ah ha ha
it was Timmy it wasn't Jimmy my boy
Timmy as mom's [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
Hulk Hogan come on bro God come on
brother get dim it sir alright let's see
let's just do this one so there's a new
business on barstool sports there's a
new game called active shooter that's
not that's not in good taste
yes so you can actually be the active
shooter and it you can go into schools
in this game how this how this is so
offensive to me how the [ __ ] does this
game and you could or you could be the
SWAT guy that goes and how does it get
done I don't know that's why that forum
that's why even barstools like they
don't want to feel like old fuddy
buddies whatever but they feel like this
is too much - yeah no [ __ ] is too much
[ __ ] whoever made the kids being killed
14 year olds being shot in the face also
promoting it yeah and you're promoting
ain't allowed these future boys just do
it a way to the guy's an [ __ ] man
that's a game company seen what yeah
[ __ ] do you should be out of business
hey steam [ __ ] you what a piece of [ __ ]
just boycott it [ __ ] oh just yeah
everyone should boycott steam everyone
should go to the [ __ ] place of
business and boycott a [ __ ] yeah
alright a little update on Roseanne you
know how she's blaming ambien do you
know if she's blaming yeah and she's a
rabbit so she she's not racist she
blames the ambien she'd done she's done
like really bad things when on ambien
before like also every time it's so
idiot
so every time she tweets she's on
ambient also every time she's ever said
something racist or condescending
towards minorities it's she's on ambient
so ambien the company they actually
responded to her and they responded by
Aguirre and Z that's what the left seven
people all races my take it I fall
asleep when I wake up hating blacks all
rights just people all races religions
nationalities work at cinephile happen
at every day to improve the lives of
people around the world so now phase the
pharmaceutical company under which MBS
sold they go on while all pharmaceutical
treatments have side effects racism is
not a known side effects by step on
medication may cause bloody stool and
racism Wow I think Rosen's an idiot yeah
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and also I don't think she wanted to do
the show any longer what do you think
about so people are talking about having
this show go on without her oh yeah do
Roseanne without Rosa dude well freakin
John Goodman he's huge what are you
doing like they've mentioned another
show called Valerie do you membership
Valerie and then the show went on
without her she's Sara Gilbert would be
the would be the they're thinking about
Sir Gilbert being the star of it but and
good luck it's a bad idea but it helps
the everyone I don't know sure I think
people realize when a show like this
canceled that's this big
it affects probably putana people at
least children under 200 rpm hundreds
and now ABC right now ABC hasta their
banker their top summer program they
have a huge gap and I'll lead in what
and also you wanted the eight eight
o'clock spot is their spot on Tuesday
the eight thirty spot was amazing big
ten spots out to follow that but then
also she's going after her fellow
co-workers to like Sykes remember psyche
I wanted something out she goes you're
the reason the show got canceled you
made everyone nervous when he tweeted
that out and she even went on and like
the her daughter who plays her daughter
on the program unbelievable unbelievable
Wow
because she tweed like we do not agree
with Rose yeah yeah she's an idiot
something's wrong with him well Dan and
she and from what I hear she didn't like
doing this just like the show sucked
they thought you know a lot of things
that was going on she didn't agree with
so maybe she didn't like the director I
think it's a little bit of some she
wanted out yes oh she made Sara Sara
Gilbert producer apparently cuz she
didn't want to deal with the production
of it and stuff so I don't know huh
well she found her way out she was hated
woman in the world right now what else
yet I don't know much about football but
this lineman for the Kansas City Chiefs
Wow medical degree Wow Lance still it
goes like the Harvard of yeah it was a
great school wrong Duvernay tardif is
his name he's juggled dual love scroll
imagine it has dual dual
responsibilities as a guard from Kansas
City Chiefs as a medical student at
Montreal's McGill University is now free
to she's only on football yeah came a
doctor Tuesday when he graduated from a
Gil's Medical School
dan that's pretty cool awesome what a
beast yeah yep and I think tardy might
be a Muslim name - so he's from East
french-canadian but he probably has a
Syria is from Algeria laurent de tarif
yeah wrong de truth wow that's amazing
that's pretty cool
awesome since this day I got drafted I
promised myself I was gonna finish my
studies and get that empty while still
playing which is unheard of some of
these life projects that you promised
yourself you're going to accomplish and
it's hold on hold on
so I might have missed that huh he's
current and he was acting steady and
point and say he was retired how the
[ __ ] do you do that and that's a story
yeah this guy's an amazing guy yeah
Wow now you can focus on some foosball
in his career afterwards yeah of that CT
doing chicken uh what else you get iffy
about this one televangelist he has
already three private jets and he's
asking you know people that follow him
for a fourth private jet cuz that's what
God told him yeah there are a lot of
ponies yeah I mean can I just pray on it
yeah and pray on it for me I see him
talking cuz I'm sure he was here awesome
- he needs four Jets what 7x so we can
go anywhere in the world one star
so you can spread his message to more
places what's a 54 million dollar
private yes I got it cuz you don't want
to stop the preacher has already
purchased three private planes oh my god
please God to him he needs us it's in
the Bible amen cousin and then a great
statement that he told me in 1978
flooded into my mind is Jesse I didn't
ask you to pay for it
oh my god that's gonna help us that's
basically all you think he's gonna get
it preaching the gospel of the Lord
Jesus Christ and if Jesus was
specifically on earth today it wouldn't
be riding a donkey it would not be on a
donkey dude if Jesus was food everywhere
with a dog wouldn't I be riding a donkey
would be riding a sidesaddle and he
wouldn't be riding a donkey
God what a con artist what and you know
what you know it's a little crazy
he might get it but he gets that faster
and cheaper dude it makes sense
come on it's only fifty four million
dollars that's not that big a deal
see you gotta get there quicker I got my
own source of fuel so I can spread word
what easier and I ain't sittin luxury
yeah and and I believe that it's not
like he doesn't get taxed right because
it's a church I don't know how it works
yeah you're right so Wow no I have to
raise fifty four so for me I want to buy
fifty four million dollars yet I gotta
make one hundred million dollars right
so not him it's hilarious
this guy it's real too no one happening
where do I get where how about is that
the church wall where is this picture of
his place sure it is clean private plane
he's a dig amazing he's a dick and I'm a
he's amazing in a dick way yeah he's an
amazing day some con men and he's a con
man some cons apart and if you're gonna
be a comment you got to believe your own
con is it as an acting teacher told me
Kahneman the good con men believe what
they're saying when they're saying it
you got to believe because then the
other person will believe it's called
being a sociopath it's called being a
true pathological narcissist
it's not about possessions it's about
priorities he's amazing the way you
really go I think now he goes on now
how're we gonna do that
I can't live long enough to travel by
car or by ship or by train but I can do
a by airplane yep
it's not about possession as he's in a
custom as a 51 year on all my young
listeners please beware be aware of
anybody who speaks in in catchy
sentences it's it's a really because
what happens is you'll start repeating
them and catchy sentences sounds they
sound true and don't do that about
possessions I don't get Smouse you're
young with a charismatic leader you'll
buy it and that's how charismatic
leaders get followers banners slogans
catchy phrases you can see it all this
60s I just feel now if you're if
anyone's rhyming to sell anything it's
it's it's wolf take it I three billion
people do it all the time still do it
they don't smell it
believe me motivational speakers do it
out it's incredible that's the number
one thing it's incredibly was trying to
sell this you know you know that the 50
billion dollar man that guy Dan Pena who
did Rogen's podcast
he's on London real - I was like they
said he makes 15 million dollars but 50
billion dollars but they've been on
there been people you know people on
reddit and people who do like that
journalists who do like be repeat the
BBC the BBC tried to interview him but
they needed to verify how rich he was
well it costs you I think something like
something like $20,000 just to pay for a
seminar where you go to his castle in
Scotland its that resided but nobody can
find he can't provide any documentation
for what he's really worth you know he
can find it and as far as they know
there's just no evidence to that and the
people that take his classes that stuff
doesn't really work because like I say I
had a short pharmaceutical companies all
kinds of stuff and those people who take
classes and and up starting their own
online videos no following he's got a
big following but if you actually look
at
the details if you actually ask for the
real proof of what how much he's worth
the BBC couldn't do an interview with
him because they were like we can't
verify there's no way to verify what his
net worth is thing where he just doesn't
want people knowing his net worth uh
sure okay he's the one who says he's the
fifty billion dollar man so if you don't
go [ __ ] Castle he's doing something
right right uh sure
not fifty in a really Scotland okay baby
huh
whether he has money or not I'm sure he
has money well sure is a ton of money
yeah it's from Jacksonville Florida it's
pretty interesting there's there's been
some I read some interesting things
about it that's all he's a business
coach and a lot of people that have if
you look at people I like stuff that
he's talking about doesn't trying to do
that stuff takes a long time and Finance
to be really good at very sophisticated
you're not gonna take a [ __ ] week
seminar are three days and learning and
that's what he's saying you seen it all
you see make goes back to that there are
three things you need to know to create
well these kinds of it's the same [ __ ]
we talk everyone's doing it though yeah
he's just so really rich just be aware
of people sure he's good at it but you
know he's finding a way of just good at
that's what I'm saying there's no
evidence that he's that wealthy there
just isn't
I bet he's wealthy if you owned a castle
you but you have ten million dollars and
have a castle depending on where it is
right it all depends and he makes money
now he makes twenty million dollars
twenty thousand dollars a person who
takes his business coach yeah but
whether or not
so he's successful maybe not 50 billion
successful yeah maybe not even close to
a billion maybe not even close to 50
million that's what I'm saying there's
just he the BBC asked him they wanted to
interview him he does all kinds of
interviews and he didn't want to do it
be leaders yet place like BBC he's not
gonna interview you unless they've done
their due diligence so it was
interesting I did a little I did a
little poking around that's all cuz I
was like curious if I listen to him
speak he had days Baskar I've listened
to two podcasts with him and I was like
hmm something isn't feeling right just
my experience I'm just I I just like I'm
when I watched so much of this online
people who are gonna tell you how to get
rich over there all clear feeding on the
sheets think it's all [ __ ] yeah yeah
what else yet gin um how about I've
never heard of him be do you guys watch
Walking Dead at all
I used to I watched the first season a
half then I fell out of it did you ever
watch it right yeah oh you still watch
it or no nope
okay cuz I used to watch it too it's
Walking Dead what's the other one
Walking Dead I know there's Walking Dead
and then if you're walking through yeah
I watch that too anyhow Angelique and
the starve it's gonna leave next season
and because of that the other star
Norman Reedus they're giving him 20
million dollars to stay ahead man get
paid damn
I really worked out for him oh yeah cuz
they didn't want all the guys leaving I
mean there's even that dude 29 years old
that's another crazy holy [ __ ] he looks
good saw him the other day in a
restaurant wow he looks good good good
actor just set it here on them yeah
Jesus Christ it's a hard show to shoot i
watch it all the time I was in Atlanta
those extras to play zombies I'm not a
makeup you're not make it you're fine
and you're standing there waiting and
you're also like it's not like all the
time no no that's me well that doesn't
look like you're just getting killed and
walking maybe you've seen me as a zombie
or Walking Dead and they're shooting in
the outskirts now I watch them oh my god
be a bee keep that nose out through it
you gotta be really serious all the time
there's no no thank you
good mom dude you like that song yeah
yeah is that it over this kitchen yeah
you want more how many more okay well
this one I have not seen yet it's a
movie on Netflix
I just called Monica saw last night you
saw it okay so you're here although
everyone talking about like they can't
finish it cuz it's too scary that's
[ __ ] okay so as your marketing for
let me type this I remember personally I
thought it was just okay just okay I got
bored Wow yeah what's the last movie
like that was scary like it
what's the last movie like that was
scary though
you know what I liked we got roasted I'm
quiet place that's movies you ever see
yeah that's so dramatic I don't care
some yeah eat some guy until I got a
[ __ ] off so we guys hold the [ __ ] up
I went there with my girl date night cuz
you too and check the [ __ ] up about it
there's no talking it was good
why she scared the [ __ ] out because I
need takes only right number though
there are a lot of movies that scared
the [ __ ] out of me like the conjuring
and then 100 two's all right conjuring
is really what's the one where insidious
I saw that one two three yeah I saw a
prime come on
why bro believe me come on where were
they where they would sleep and [ __ ]
would happen when they were sleeping in
the house oh [ __ ]
Paranormal Activity watching the second
one when the girls up on the [ __ ]
when she's up on the fridge you know
women are supposed to back ah like that
I swear to god she's right actually and
she flips out when a woman thinks she
goes uh she screamed like a grizzly bear
in my ear I was like when you get scared
your voice gets deep I was like that's
not a trap I was on board to let
paradise it's such a crime scene ever I
mean conjuring when first came out was
[ __ ] scary what's that one with the
two sisters like they're their little
girls they grew up by themselves oh and
then had a mouse well mom whorfin was
scary the shining scared the [ __ ] out of
me angel heart scared the [ __ ] out amis
are all songs The Exorcist
The Omen scary Exorcist is good oh my
god they scared there's some good ones
oh yeah I'll watch this one though it's
uh it's in Spanish I think so I watch a
ton of science TV it's also based on a
true story so I don't know that or not
guys right sure events or any like
paranormal activity
shut up Brendan you've been a little
harsh on me today now but yeah you're
making fun of my my loads on you do look
tough I'll just be not how you talk okay
what am i do we got a bunch of kratom
for you though
hey man I got me a shitload of kratom
over there all right now are you setting
kratom sure ain't really why would you
really like Chris Bell oh you're not at
all what pain do we have are you
Oh might as well you've been you yeah
acht about it that's not use it for I
use the original for pain but then it
doesn't really work for my pain anymore
so what do you take it for relaxation Oh
cuz your dick this yo so you dig you dig
data I can go an hour without it man an
hour hey man can you take kratom yeah
you were the first one to tell me about
yeah you're doing drugs that's what's
going on that's all that's why you're me
it's illegal then I wouldn't do it well
it is illegal if it gets banned here
then I'm gonna have to stop really yeah
good luck with that does know there's
paranormal activity scaring me scaring
me $13 to make it scary scary we watch
that movie oh what's that movie the
other one the first one that was ever
found where they found the flue age
which was great why's that blur which
was scary when you thought it was real
watch it when you die no real we want
sit in my buddy Gavin Jimin I watched it
and then they were like oh yeah then we
were sitting around then after like five
minutes
Gavin just goes lob suck two hours back
if you think it's real though like I
remember when I went to the theater in
Denver the small is like old-school
theater that is the only one planet is
so scary and it's real not their
marketing brilliant yeah and I was like
so [ __ ] sketches we thought was
really like oh my god
worth what the [ __ ] but then like months
later we came out with fake
you want to know like this might be the
last
yes didn't you want to a camping after
that the [ __ ] no like with your friends
that we're safe
no okay Scout was really scary I thought
oh yeah you gotta catch a plane B love
you guys I'll see you in Minnesota this
weekend Thursday Friday Saturday next
weekend we got Raleigh North Carolina
good nights and then you [ __ ] him guys
we didn't take a picture with Chris chin
yeah we didn't take your pictures Chris
oh I thought you guys are walking out
sure all right
we'll have to get off the tire Hall July
19th we had our show get your tickets
Talia hall seeing helium June 21 22 23
Brendan were you gonna be with the ice
house June 15th one show one night only
that thing's almost sold out in June
22nd 23rd Houston improv get tix now
defect kake.com that's it this is the
fire kid Ralph